All right, that's sure how to interpret these results compared.
Been doing a cutters clinic program for ER plus breast cancer since October 16.
My results are CEA November 1.8 in December 1.3.
CA 1999 November less than 2, less than 3.
So this is the CA 1999 is basically a mute point for you.
CEA is within normal range for you.
CA 125, this one it seems I got closer to the upper range.
32 and 37.
Again, even if this is the same lab, a change a difference from 32 to 37.
That's still within the margin of error there.
So I would even be concerned about that CA 15 3 29.8 to 22.
Well, that you're starting to go a little bit beyond the margin of error in the good direction.
So that's good.
See the difference in what different lab calls normal 0 to 25 was lab core and quest is then less than 32.
Just a little bit different range difference.
There's nothing set and stolen with ranges.
How do I read this sense?
One went up and the other went down, but they're all still within normal range.
You're still doing your I'd say you're doing great.
You just don't want them to spike.
So what you're looking for, let's say, see, let's look at the CA 27 29 as an example.
This is really the only one that.
Well, this one of the CA 15 3 that you can really use markers because they're the only ones that are.
They're the only ones that are being outside of normal.
And you see even the 29.8 would have ended within normal range on the quest lab.
Because these these normal ranges are not set in stone.
They're just something that.
You know, lab that that.
The medical fresheners picked over a period of time that this is within normal range.
It's just like when I graduated back in the 1980s, normal cholesterol was, you know, if you were abnormal.
If you were over 250, then they dropped it down to to 20, then 200 and now it's 180.
Why? Because they can sell more drugs to lipitor to people if they dropped the normal doubt.
Yeah, I'm sorry, it's cynical, but it's true.
How do I read these? I'd say you're looking for changes.
How you read your labs, you're looking for changes and you're looking for fairly, fairly dramatic changes.
So a change from 32 to 37. Oh, that went up.
Yeah, well, it's still kind of within the within range of what you think is not really a jump.
If you're looking at if you had a jump from 32 to 58, you know, okay, that's a jump.
That's what you're looking for. Gross changes like that.
So another word on tour markers. It's like, okay, you have a tour marker of, you know, let's look at your CA, 909 of less than two, right?
That means it's normal in people with even no cancer to have a CA, 909.
If you had a, if yours was 25, you know, zero to 35 is normal.
So this isn't specifically telling a person that they have cancer.
You can have this enzyme marker, even if you don't have cancer.
So that's why they're just markers. They're not definitive diagnostic tests. They're just markers. They give us clues.
So when you look at these, you run them first to get kind of a baseline.
And now you're looking for, you know, major changes. So what you'd be concerned with is if your CA 153 was 298 back in November.
And now it's 74 in December. That would be a red flight concert.